we're almost done with our baseline data
ml and AI quest in this episode
I'll introduce you to the data studio
quick start over on quick labs data
studio lets you create dynamic visually
compelling reports and dashboards with
data studio you can easily connect to a
variety of data sources visualize your
data through attractive dynamic and
interactive reports and dashboards and
share and collaborate with others just
like Google Drive this lab will take you
only 30 minutes to complete and you'll
learn how to create a new report add a
data source to the report add a chart to
the report and style your report however
you want through three simple steps
connecting to your data visualizing that
data to gain insights and sharing and
collaborating on reports produced data
studio helps you tell great data stories
to better support business decisions
you're only one lab away from completing
your quest and getting your badge in
case you haven't been following our
other videos a quest is a series of
related labs that form a learning path
on quick labs completing this quest
earns you this badge to recognize your
achievement next up on our quest Google
genomics QuickStart
[Music]